bajo la disyuntiva de permanecer
durmiendo a la intemperie o ingresar
bajo ecuación al nuevo campamento de
karate p así se encuentran miles de
refugiados varados en la isla de lesbos
casi una semana después del incendio que
arrasó con moria el mayor campo de
refugiados de europa este marte las
autoridades griegas han detenido a cinco
migrantes por su presunta implicación en
el siniestro tristes temores los
pirómanos de moria están en custodia son
cinco jóvenes extranjeros estamos
buscando uno más a los años en las
inmediaciones de moria los refugiados se
rehúsan a ingresar en el nuevo campo y
están siendo persuadidos a través de
folletos informativos por las
autoridades griegas que aseguran que es
la única vía para solicitar asilo y es
el infierno número dos yo ya estaba en
la cárcel porque estar en moria es estar
en la cárcel así que vengo aquí veo
gente coches entrando no no quiero no
entraré ahí
esa crisis humanitaria en el seno de la
unión europea sigue exacerbando las
tensiones con los locales que se oponen
a que se establezca un nuevo campamento
para maestros
el cuadro es realmente terrible las
cosas están empeorando y si terminan el
campo y el tiempo pasa lo quemaran de
nuevo esta gente quiere irse deben
ponerlos en botes y llevarlos a donde
quieran ir porque los mantienen aquí
cuanto más tiempo se queden más se
sienten como prisioneros porque no los
dejan salir
en medio de los llamados del gobierno
griego a la solidaridad del bloque
europeo con lo que es un problema común
alemania anunció que acogerá mil 553
refugiados exhaustos del abandono
institucional de años